we got to talk about this story all
right we got the story from reason
this gun shop says it won't do business
with biden voters yeah in missouri
no in michigan oh tech companies should
have the same freedom to choose their
customers so this is a michigan-based
ammunition shop
is refusing to sell to any customer who
voted for president joe biden in the
2020 election quote
we've had a few potential customers call
this morning ask why they have to check
a box
stating they did not vote for joe biden
in order to purchase our ammunition
phoenix ammunition tweeted yesterday
morning the answer joe biden ran on a
campaign built on the most radical gun
control platform
a major party candidate has ever had
including banning the online sale of
ammunition
this says phoenix is essentially a plan
to bankrupt our company that's true
i couldn't believe when i read that joe
biden said we will ban the online sale
of ammo
why what what's seriously the problem
there
that that that's great because they're
just their whole plan is like we're
going to throw as much sand
in the gears of gun ownership as we can
for what reason but but also you have to
look at strategically here this is
against the best interest of the united
states national security one of the
things that makes america strong
is its armed citizenry when you take
away the arms geopolitically we
we become weaker on the world stage well
i mean like
what since when has like what's good for
the american people stopped democrat
ideas
well like political ideologically i
would say political idea
and i want to be fair too republican
gets excluded from that because
republicans mostly do nothing
yeah right what did trump do for the
second amendment i mean
nothing well no he did worse he did bad
for yeah banning bumps i mean
really the big proposition you know the
value proposition of republican
governance
is that they won't do more bad things
not that they'll do good things to
improve your life
but they'll just they'll just avoid
doing the bad thing but when it comes to
trump
and the bump stock ban he went further
than democrats would have even wished
democrats usually uh grandfather in
people and their firearms and their
accessories donald trump
made americans felons overnight with the
signing of a pen
something that of course democrats
weren't able to do trump did
i want to read more of this so uh
there's another quote they say
uh in a series of follow-up tweets the
company stressed that it was perfectly
willing to give up potential sales to
people who voted for biden
we're dead serious phoenix ammunition
tweeted we don't want your money
and you shouldn't want us to have it
because we're going to use it to make
more ammo
sell it to the citizenry and do
everything in our power to prevent joe
biden's administration from usurping the
rights of americans
we have no problem talking to biden
voters and educating them on what they
did
but they have to be willing to
acknowledge their ignorance at the very
least
we're not going to sit here and debate
with you we're a 2a company
and these are our first principles
phoenix ammunition's announcement has
provoked a wave of positive attention
from the right
many are applauding the company for
sticking up for its beliefs and
declining do business
with people it sees as a threat to its
business model i love this
quote private company tweeted perennial
maga gadfly jack pasobic
the implication being that because
phoenix is private it can do what it
wants
he's right of course phoenix is
perfectly within its rights to reject
customers who voted for biden
or for any other reason related to a
person's politics not in dc by the way
in dc politics political idea ideology
is a human right
and then they go on to say i love this
and so is twitter and youtube and
facebook and reddit and so on
yet when it comes to these private
companies rejecting customers based on
their ideological beliefs and political
statements
the soviet and many many others on the
right have been whining
and objecting nonstop they insist it
violates their rights somehow
they champion proposals to force these
private actors to carry speech they
disagree with
and cater to customer bases they find
objectionable they support
federal action to punish private
businesses for not being politically
neutral so which is it who who wrote
this and why are they simple is it
robbie
no it's elizabeth nolan brown it's
reason come on reason yeah
libertarians yeah so they don't get that
it's like jack's joking right
right if you actually go to jack and you
say here's the deal we can regulate
private companies
and prevent them from discriminating
against you politically on facebook and
twitter but here's what you have to give
up you're the random gun shop in
michigan also has to serve biden voters
he'd be like uh yeah i'll take the
regulations right right right
you know he's clearly joking saying
private company
is poking fun at all of the people this
is really funny where libertarians break
from a lot of conservatives and you know
one one of these issues and they're more
aligned with liberals on this one that
so well actually let me just say somehow
that happened when did when did pro
corporate libertarians you know i should
say pro corporate but pro
private right for companies break from
conservatives on the issue and join
the liberals well it's more like the
liberals were always for the regulations
you know
the liberals realized both the liberals
and conservatives actually hold
political power at times libertarians
don't
so that that's kind of where you start
um and so
liberals realize that it assisted them
in their attempts to hold and wield
political power
if they were going to indulge the right
of corporations to censor their
ideological adversaries
and so liberals who under in any other
context would never talk about how
private companies can do whatever they
want
uh are suddenly saying oh actually now
facebook and twitter are uniquely in the
position where they should be given full
autonomy
um whereas conservatives are you know
like me are also you know generally
being like no generally the free
market's a good idea but i'm sorry i
don't like being discriminated against
right that's the difference between
absolute like bottom of the spectrum
libertarianism of
you know free-for-all essentially and
well we need some government we need
some regulations
i'd love to hear a libertarian explain
why if you know given this position that
they have of like oh
you should never interfere with the
private companies right to do what they
want um how
they whether or not they could oppose in
these 1964 civil rights act and support
the repeal
of that law they do support their appeal
of it some do but like
many don't or and many certainly aren't
willing to talk about it i mean i
actually did it like joe jorgensen
yeah i did debate with robbie suavey on
this and he just assembled
horribly on it i love robbie but like he
he had a rough time when you know
he was talking about the right of
facebook and twitter center people i'm
like okay it's like
do you you know oppose the 1964 civil
rights act he's like well yeah i do i'm
like okay so you're for
you know hotels and restaurants
discriminating being able to
discriminate against black people he's
like well you know and
it's just it's the craziest thing
because i've never moved on this
position
like i've always been in this like this
this was the center left
pro regulation when corporations were
interfering with the rights of
individuals becoming too powerful
that's when the people band together and
say you have too much power and it's
causing us harm
so you know interestingly like this is
where you know the libertarians were
educated like i feel like i was educated
in this way that
was saying like actually you know you
know really the problem was government
and you know all those civil rights they
would have been protected and
and the issue was government
intervention and goldwater was right the
civil rights act went too far and then
you know i look back at that you know 10
or 12 years ago will i'm like that was
dumb why did i believe that that that
was clearly
like historically wrong and just very
very ideological
well you know you know the story behind
how like uh i
this is one of the stories of how we saw
the end of segregation was i think it
was lyndon johnson
he had some black men who worked for him
and he asked them i told you the story
you told me the story there yeah
oh what did you write this up for human
events yeah i wrote this out there tell
the story
it's a brilliant story so i mean this is
in uh robert carroll's biography
right but so lyndon johnson had these
uh you know had black employees and a
couple of them he had drive his car
all the way back to texas from dc every
year
and um there usually wasn't a big deal
but one year he wanted them to take his
their
his dog back with him and they were like
please don't make us do that
and one that's like why like what's the
big deal you have a dog in the car who
cares and
he's like do you understand what it's
like to drive through the jim crow south
with a car like we have to drive you
know 40 miles
off the main drag just to find a place a
hotel or a restaurant
like and then and many times we just
have to sleep in the car
uh and we have to do that now with a dog
too are you kidding
and it was sort of that moment that was
just crystallized like wait we don't
have to let that happen
like we could you know whatever's going
on in the south we don't have to
tolerate
people not being able to go to a motel
or a restaurant
on the road and having to go we just
don't have to tolerate that we can say
that that's illegal now
um and to me that's just really powerful
of
you know you can come up with all these
you know rationalizations and
hypotheticals about what would have
happened in the absence of some
early horrible government intervention
and every bad thing is the fruit of that
early government intervention like
libertarians to
try to argue you know i hear a lot from
libertarians that oh eventually these
businesses would have failed and their
competition would have succeeded
i think the key word is eventually like
how long would that take
and i think maybe is the right word but
here's another here's another point like
put yourself in the position
of a a restauranteur or a motel owner in
the jim crow south just on some random
you know stretch of highway are you
making money hand over fist
in the 1960s no you're not
right you're a restaurateur in the jim
crow south in the 1960s
so in you know in the abstract like if
some
black person came in even even if you
had like maybe where someone inclined to
racism you might say like
well we need the money so we're
perfectly happy to serve you but
the problem was there was this private
like the problem was like this
widespread racist disgust among the
customer base
and so you know if there were so many
white customers who were racist and
would not
stay in a motel that that was integrated
and so that private consumer demand for
discrimination
was sustaining the racism and there's no
there was no
you know that would have continued the
libertarians are wrong that would have
just continued on right
um and i think i mean think about all
how the private this private
discrimination is being used now i mean
it's
again not the same quality much worse to
be racist
but we see how progressives act today
how they try and use collective pressure
to exclude conservatives from public
life like
well how does the market solve that a
really good example that there is a
problem of ideology
is gina carano posts a tweet disney
fires her lucasfilm fires her
so when an individual employee her as
the star of the show the mandalorian
says something political the company
says oh we can't allow that that's
offensive you're fired
you then know the story of this uh this
uh restaurant
where one employee wanted to wear a
black lives matter mask and the business
said basically the same thing disney did
you can't have that you can't wear it
sorry so the activists got the business
shut down it doesn't matter if you're
the employer or the employee when you
oppose the cult they come after you
that's what i think is funny about this
gun shop story is that you have one gun
shop who's saying we don't want to do
business with biden voters well how many
businesses have
turned around and said we don't want to
do any business with trump supporters
like
exactly maybe not huge corporations
aren't publicly saying that but
i've seen small businesses on instagram
and facebook posting and saying if
you're a trump supporter we don't want
your money
that's the funny there was that remember
that video where the vape shop guy
screaming at the top of his lungs
because guys wearing a maga hat
like dude it's one thing when phoenix
ammunition is like
you know uh hello there good sir uh but
a biden voter i'm sorry take your
business elsewhere it's another thing
when a guy walks with a maga hat and the
vape store guy goes
you're screaming as loud as he can it's
so mundane discriminate that's where
discrimination conservatives against
conservatives is so mundane that we
don't even talk about it it's not even
news
right it's news when a conservative
business discriminates against liberals
not the reverse
yeah right i mean it was meme worthy
when the guy was screaming
the guy's like i'm wearing a hat bro
what's wrong with you so does this prove
that the government intervention didn't
work
in into and now in our current modern
day circumstances well no i mean there
is no government
prohibition on political discrimination
right but there is a government
prohibition on racial discrimination and
i think honestly when you're looking for
things like government policies that
work that ultimately achieve their
objective
i think the civil rights act of 1964 you
can fairly say achieved its objective i
think it accelerated
um you know it massively accelerated
integration in the jim crow south and
um here's radically transformed but do
you think we're regressing especially
with some i i forgot what this picture
was from but there was a mandatory
meeting
uh people of color had to go in one
place people said white people had to go
yeah it was in seattle
do you think we're regressing back into
that sure i think we are um but that i
think that particular type of
discrimination is definitely vulnerable
to lawsuits
um i think and chris ruffo i don't know
if you've had them on yet oh yeah okay
so chris ruffo's awesome and i think
he's whenever the left tries to go so
far and actually do
does wants to do racial discrimination
on its own it's vulnerable to having the
civil rights act brought in
to wield against it the political
discrimination problem on the other hand
like we don't currently have the law we
kind of need except in maybe a few
jurisdictions i think california and dc
have some political discrimination
protections but in general i think like
that's that's got to be a project of the
right to say
look the free market is not going to
save us it and and i think
it's it's it's it's yeah there's not a
free market the pro
republicans are not going to do that
mitch mcconnell you know you don't
his professional you know i'll give him
a catchphrase slow down there are
democrats that's it that's what he does
i mean he he might not do it but he's
old and
he may not be in office too much longer
and i think about i'm more optimistic on
this front
because you know two years ago i was
saying platform access is a civil right
and people were calling me crazy
like leftist they're calling me like
michael mouse did that you know i
actually talked to akami
you know he didn't call me akami but
he's like you're coming from leftists
background and you know i basically you
know i
redid his podcast and it's just
everybody's sort of come around
to where i was two years ago in this
radical position i had a conversation
with a libertarian
in milwaukee at the mythicist event and
i wasn't i wasn't there to be
then i ended up doing and i ended up on
a panel because someone wasn't able to
make it but i was i was in the green
room
and there was a bunch of sitting around
talking to this libertarian and i said
we need regulation of big tech companies
in some capacity be it
the the ensuring of the freedom freedom
of speech because they've taken the
commons
or some kind of regulation that says we
need to like reform of section 230
and he said i don't i don't believe you
have a right to tell a private
institution what they're allowed to do
and i was like dude i've heard the
argument i don't care
if you want to sit back while your ideas
are completely erased from the public
space
by all means do it because my idea is
i'm not a libertarian i'm actually in
favor of regulation
and that's what i'm arguing for so in
five years when you d when your
political ideology is gone it doesn't
exist
who's gonna who's gonna argue for you
but also i think we need to make a
distinction between private business and
also monopolies that control information
highways
and also monopolies specifically that
are connected to governments in many
different ways so i think there's a
difference between the the
you know the the cake owner versus
twitter facebook
oh yeah you know i randomly get
questions from people who say things
like well if you
if you think you should regulate twitter
why well how could you possibly oppose
regulating the cake owner
i don't i'm like i well for my answer to
that is
i mean i think that's a perfectly
consistent position to think you should
regulate both
yeah right but i think that it's okay
for society to impose larger burdens
on billion dollar companies than on
small entrepreneurs
that's right like it already does that
we do that in insurance we do that in
common carrier
i mean there's so many different areas
of law that treat
think obamacare even right small
businesses are treated very differently
than larger businesses so that's one of
my first arguments in that
when a when a corporation grows large
enough to
cause damage to the public we then come
in with regulations
one bakery saying i refuse one thing or
another
is not causing massive damage to the
entirety of
the the area however in the in the in my
actual
position is look when it comes to the
bakery what people need to understand
and most people who watch us probably do
they didn't deny service they denied a
custom message
so the baker basically said you could
have any cake that we
or or we can custom make one for you but
we won't write that
and so they sued over it my position is
i know a lot of people don't like taxes
libertarians don't like taxes
taxation is theft for the time being if
i'm paying taxes to sustain
a common area common infrastructure
pipes sidewalks police fire department
ems all of that stuff and you are using
that
infrastructure to support your business
that means we are all contributing to
the betterment of your business i
believe
you have you have an obligation to
reasonably service
the public if someone comes in is
committing crimes screaming disruptive
disorderly
threatening all that stuff by all means
we kick them out because that's you know
an affront to everyone in the public
but if we're all contributing to the
space to work and live together
and i come into your shop i understand
the argument about the free speech and
being forced to write something and
that's a good argument so i'm kind of on
the fence on that one
but overall i think businesses should
provide a
you know equal accommodation to members
of the public and i i think that's a cl
much closer question
than the question of whether or not it's
just to regulate twitter which i think
is
very one-sided in favor of yes it's
perfectly just to regulate them
i mean they're a multi-billion dollar
company that's monopolized a large
section
of this public square and that people's
first and
right now people's first round amendment
rights aren't really that meaningful i
mean think about how much
just you know we've done donald trump
has been banned from twitter for six
weeks think about how much the volume's
been turned down on him
from losing his twitter account yeah
well it's not just twitter i mean
you can go walk down the street and have
a different baker bake a cake
but you know what you could go to parlor
not anymore i mean i guess now they came
back but
before you go to parlor and then parlor
got shut down and yeah there's a big
difference between private space and and
government monopolies
that's the thing that we need to really
really uh you know beat into people's
heads the
the one of the ways i put it when it
comes social media and why regulation is
important
is you so like you said you can go to
one baker and he says no so you walk
down the street another baker he says
yes there's market competition you can
probably find something
even if parlor exists twitter
is basically the la coliseum football
stadium
the president is in the middle of the
field yelling all of his ideas to the
people
and they kick you out and you can walk a
few miles away to a small soccer field
at a high school
where the local principal is giving his
ideas so
do you have meaningful access to the
president and politicians who are
verified using this platform
in mass that twitter actually gives the
like will put the position they have as
a politician in their
under their name they recognize
politicians aren't using a bunch of
these other platforms
so the problem i see is sure there may
be some competition there may be parlor
there may be mines
trump doesn't use any of them so are you
going to be able to hear the president
speak
imagine if when television was invented
a radio
when if the president was gonna was
going to give an address they showed up
to your house and said you can't have
the radio on here the president they
came in and turned it off on you
i mean people don't have access to cbs
or nbc anymore you can't yeah
we where they they put a giant metal
dome over your house you can't get any
radio waves we've banned you from
collecting this information
it's crazy to me that they restrict you
from even hearing
maybe the answer is to ban people from
posting but not from following
you know what i mean well i mean you can
make the argument they already do that
because you can always like
lurk on even if you've been banned from
twitter you can lurk and read
why why ban you from subscribing to the
president's posts because you said
something instead of banning your right
to say something
well what they did to trump is like they
kicked him out of the coliseum and then
burned the soccer field down
i mean he's he's been from spotify yeah
like
what is he going to do like listening to
too much music like
he's been from pinterest when he's going
to plan a wedding right like
it doesn't make sense i love when like
twitch banned him yeah like oh no the
president's gonna play minecraft and
and espouses ideology to kids who are
building twitch were smart they would
have just allowed the president on and
like massively built up their platform
donald trump playing minecraft what is
this green guy doing
why is he constantly trying to get me i
don't understand
that'd been hilarious thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content
segments you can't get anywhere else go
to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you